Haley Chris and Matt big fans especially
you Chris you're my boys
stand up of all your stuff dude Matt
you're cool too again
basically I've Got A Sitch with my
girlfriend
um turns out she likes girls and I'm
super supportive obviously and I'm proud
that she came out and told me about it
but it hurts because I felt like I was
doing something wrong but after some
talking we realized no just something
that obviously she can't help and
nothing really
sort of woke that up in her that just
how she is I love her the same I
actually though want your guys advice on
am I an [__] if I want to still try
to make it work with her what because
she's kind of my everything and I can't
really imagine life without her
um
do you think there's a way we could stay
together
even though now I know that she likes
girls
it's a tough one and if you guys think I
should just break up too let me know
anyways love the show so much keep
rocking it you guys are awesome what's
tough about that does she still love you
dude this is the greatest thing that's
ever happened to this guy what the [__]
was that oh that's a hero but no but
like what is the pr she's saying I don't
love you I only that's different then
obviously you shouldn't be with her if
she's like a [__] idiot well she's
gonna break up with you but also if
she's saying I also like women but I my
feelings for you haven't changed then
obviously you stay with her that you
[__] idiot now why am I being so hard
on you because you said you threw me
some [__] scraps at the top you're
like ah man I like you too it was really
just about [__] Chris so I'm gonna
treat you with the amount of shittiness
you treated me you're a [__] idiot
either way now go ahead
um so so overboard um said you're pretty
cool you know like yeah that's not the
opposite of you saying don't don't throw
me some [__] scraps okay so yeah she
likes girls so what so what it doesn't
mean she doesn't want to be with you if
she doesn't want to be with you then
she'll break up with you don't worry
about breaking up with her yeah dude
what are you talking about second of all
third of all whatever I'm at dude uh
does she want to have fun with other
girls and you right
blind blind absolutely completely blind
hey dude I'm sorry but
yeah I mean this guy's calling with
without a problem yeah dude hey dude I
don't know what's going on man I got so
much [__] it's crazy uh it's just
falling out of my [__] pockets and
[__] I don't know how to do it I'm
trying to collect it but do you have any
containers uh what containers I should
use let's go to The Container Store but
I don't understand what's going on I got
too much [__] around I keep coming I
keep [__] and uh I make so much money
what's up dude
what's up
that's dumb but the last the assembly
line of people just sitting naked and
waiting to have sex with them they could
say dude
it would be so actually hectic if that
was your thing now
what is he saying if we had to guess
what are you talking about guy uh he is
saying
he doesn't understand what what it's
like he's like he doesn't get it you
know what he it is he doesn't
he don't got it like that right so you
could there's what you go oh hey I'm
dating a girl for a while oh hey guess
what hey hey I like girls I go like this
cool mommy who cares you're leaving me
no cool mommy you like girls me too but
guess what I'm with you yeah that's
exactly the way to think about it like
you want to introduce yourself so do I
I'm only with one can you only be with
one yep great nothing changed
nothing change Marty we're inviting
everybody over for the nothing changed
wow status quo exactly status quo
nothing changed at all
wow